외국인 투자자들이 저렇게 파는 걸
한국의 국민들 이제 그들의 용어를
빌리자면 개미들이 팔고 있 사고
있다는 거죠.
>> 네. 그래서 어 이건 또 다른 버을
만들뿐만 아니라 어디까지 얘기 운영
중에 얘기하냐면 아 저런 개인
투자자들이 어리석다. 어 왜 그런
이런 뭐 위험한 시장에서 계속 주식을
받아내 이런 투로 이제 해석이
되거든요. 그런 증거를 한번 보여
드리면 우리나라 주요 일간지들의에
최근의 상황을 분석 얘기하는 그런
헤드라인입니다. 제가 지난번에도 잠깐
말씀드렸는데 매일 경제가 오늘 뉴스를
냈는데요. 외국인들이 개미 털어 먹는
날 올 줄 알았다. 아, 이런
헤드라인을 써요. 서울 경제 볼까요?
반도체 개미들이나 살아. 아시아 경제
던지는 족적 다 받아낸다. 개미들
총알바지. 어, 저는 저게
뭐 그러는지 알았겠지만 너무 화가
났어요.
>> 예.
>> 네. 아니, 매일 경제, 서울 경제,
아시아 경제
너네들 돈은 어떻게 버는 거예요?
어, 다 국민들이 봐 줘서 돈 버는
거 아니에요? 그것 때문에 그걸
기반으로 해서 광고를 내고 있고
그래서 돈 버는 거 아닙니까? 그런데
국민들이 사는 주식을, 국민들이
바라보는 시장을 저런 식으로 해석하고
있다는 거죠. 아니, 최소한 돈을
벌어주게 하는 사람들한테는 잘해 줘야
될 거 아니야. 그런데 보는 것처럼
뭐 개미들 너네들은 아야, 뭐
개미들이나 살아, 총알바지 이런
단어를 사용한다. 이거는 굉장히
심각하다. 저 문법을 바꿔내야
된다라고 전 생각하고 있고 그래서
우리가 계속 주장하는게 뭡니까?
개미라는 용어는 있을 수 없다.
그래서 우리는 국민 투자라고 하겠다.
국민 투자자들. 저는 그런 용어를
쓰길 원하고 그런 또 운동을
해야겠어요. 그래서 우리나라
일관지들도 사실이 개미라는 단어가요.
마치 뭐 미국에서도 그러잖아.
절대요. 그렇게 쓰지 않아요.
>> 미국 리테일이라는 표현을 씁니다.
>> 맞습니다. 리테일 인베스터라고 해요.
그러니까 정확하게 투자자라는 명을
사용해요. 그래서 제가 국민
투자자라고 하는 투자자라는 명칭을
사용한 거예요. 근데 우리는 개미라고
그냥 퉁칭해서 쓰고 그러니까 개미가
어떤 특성이 있냐면 막 몰려다니고
그리고 힘은 없고 나약하고 이런
존재잖아요.
>> 그렇죠. 그래서 그런 부정적인
뉘앙스로 시장을 대한민국 주식 시장을
일종에 화하고
>> 그리고 이런 시장 상황을 어
이야기하고 있다. 그러면 예를 들어서
오늘 같은 시장 우리가 국민
투자자들이 믿음을 갖고 신뢰를 갖고
계속 사서 다시 주가가 오르는 시장은
어떻게 생각할 겁니까? 내일 기사를
한번 기대해 볼게요.
>> 네.
>> 어 그러면 뭐라까? 또 비투자해
주느니 막 이렇게 또 얘기하겠지.
그럼 외국인들 한번 얘기요.
외국인들이 사는 건 그럼 좋은
시장입니까? 아니요. 외국인들도
보세요. 돈 벌면 다 나가요.
외국인들이 온다고 해서 뭐 한국
주식의 신뢰를 갖고 막 사는 그런게
아니라고요. 외국인들은 더 치명적인
건 뭐냐면 돈만 벌려고 와요.
>> 그렇잖아요.
>> 네. 돈만 벌려고 온다고요. 근데
우리나라 국민들은 돈도 버는 것도
중요하지만 한국 국민에 대한 신뢰
그리고 한국 국가 그리고 한국
기업들에 대한 믿음을 갖고 사는 거지
않습니까? 예를 들어서 미국의
블랙락이나 이런 큰 기관이 뭐
삼성전자를 산다. 삼성전자를 좋아해서
사겠습니까? 아니 막 삼성전자
잘되기를 바라서 사겠어요? 아니요.
돈 벌려고 사는 거예요. 그래서 보는
것처럼 주가 오르면 다 나간다고요.
그래서 어쩌면 외국인 비중이 높고
외국인 투자자들이 변동성이 큰게 더
리스크한 시장일 수도 있다는 거예요.
그래서 저는 1편 과거의 문법으로
과거의 시장을 분석하는 것처럼 뭐
국민들 국민들이 사고 뭐 개미들이
살면 고점입니다. 법원입니다. 맨날
그 얘기를 하니까 계속 어떻게
물들이게 되냐면 투자자들이 불안하게
돼요. 어 개인 투자 사잖아. 뭐
동네에서 얘기해. 야, 개미가 산데.
저런 기사들을 보고 이런 거 뿌리
뽑아야 된다. 저는 그렇게
생각합니다.
>> 예. 그래서 오늘은 그 얘기를 좀
드리고 싶었어요.
>> 음.
>> 그러니까 이게 투자는요.
기술의 문제고 경제의 문제고 하지만
어쩌면 문화의 문제일 수도 있어요.
문화는 어디하고 연결되냐면 정서하고도
연결돼요. 그런 문화를 저는 잘
만들어야 된다. 우리가 이제는 주식
시장 주식 시장의 문화. 그러기
위해서는 언론이 같은 방향을 바라보고
힘을 써 줘야 됩니다. 그런데 지금
완전히 딴 방향으로 가고 있어요.
저런 신문은 봐서는 안 돼요. 이제
>> 예. 광고도 내지 말고. 네.
>> 삼성자 그런데 광고 내면 안 돼요.
이제
>> 어제는 커피숍 하나 날리시고 오늘은
이제 언론 하나 날려가고 여러번
걸리면 다 날아갑니다, 지금.
>> 네. 이제는
>> 그래서 언론들도 언론들도 같이
가야죠. 맞습니다. 방향으로 갑니까?
>> 예. 그리고 사실은 이제이 일반
국민들의이 투자에 대해서 좀 조롱하는
용어가 깔려 있고 우리가 적극적으로
분석하고 요즘 사실 굉장히 우리나라
투자자분들이 정말로 사실 우리
국민들이 세계에서 제일
똑똑하시잖아요. 정보 접근도 빠르시고
얼마나 영리하십니까?
>> 맞. 그렇죠.
>> 뭐 좋은 의미든 나쁜 의미든 성학
게임도 제일 많고 우리나라에 투자하는
분들도 지금 얼마나 영리합니까?
비트코인도 제일 많이 하시고 그러니까
>> 스마트 투자자들이에요. 사실.
>> 근데 그런 투자자들 앞에 놓고 뭐
개이다. 설거지 할 거냐 뭐 이런
얘기 한다는 거 자체가 사실은 시위에
맞지도 않고요. 틀린 얘기입니다.
>> 그 세상에 어느 나라 국민이 어
대통령을 두 번이나 끌어내립니까? 어
대단한 국민들이고 그 대단한 국민들이
지금 한국 주식을 사고 있다는 건
엄청난 일일이 벌어지고 있다는
거예요.이 변화를이 새로운 시대를
읽을 만한 준비가 되어 있는가?
으흠.
>> 전문가들이나 언론이나 시장을 분석하는
사람들이. 전 그게 안 돼 있다고
판단해요.
>> 예. 그래서 12시에 만나요만 보시면
입니다.
안녕하세요, 여러분. 여러분의 다정한
밥 친구가 되고 싶은 12시에
만나요. 이광수입니다.
아, 오늘도 주식 시장이 어김없이
열렸고요. 저희도 어김없이
찾아뵙습니다. 많은 분들 함께 해
주셔서 감사하고요. 댓글을 이렇게
올려 주시는데 어떤 분이 노트북 켜
놓고 밥 먹으러 갑니다. 아주
잘하시고 계십니다.
그리고 핸드폰 노트북 두 개로 보고
계십니다. 아주 잘하고 계십니다.
혹시 PC는 없으신가요?
여러분, 저희가 함께 열심히 해야
됩니다. 왜 동이 왜 신만이 안 되는
겁니까?
>> 여러분,
박순 대표, 우리가 언제 신만
됩니까?
>> 네. 시청해 보 지금 시청해 주시는
분들은 탓은 아니에요.
>> 네.
>> 지금 안 듣고 계신 분 탓시거든요.
>> 그럼 어떻게 거기를 설득하냐는 거죠.
안 보고 있는데.
>> 아니, 근데 저는이 근본적인 문제부터
좀 짓고 넘어가고 싶은데
>> 아니 신만이 엄청 어려운 건데
>> 엄청 어려운 거죠. 지금 유명 그
정말 오래되신 분들도 10만 원을
가는게 집가 않거든요.
>> 그죠?
>> 아니에요. 할 수 있어요. 할 수
있다고 생각해야 됩니다. 이렇게
나약하게. 예. 비교하지 마세요.
제가 투자할 때 뭐 하지 말아야
된다?
>> 비교하지 않는다.
>> 예. 비교하지 않는다. 권다영컨 님
오셨습니다.
>> 네. 10만을 위해서 달려보도록
하겠습니다.
>> 아 고맙습니다.음
별 일 없으시죠?네 네. 변일
없고요. 네. 안경을 좀 바꿔
봤습니다.
>> 아, 좋네요. 노란색에 약간 귀티가
나요.
>> 좀 귀염상으로 바꿔 보려고 약간
덩글덩글한 걸로 바꿔 왔습니다. 네.
>> 네. 권형 그 브라우스라고 하나요?
>> 네. 브라우스.
>> 그거 오늘 너무 좋은데 댓글.
>> 오늘 제가 어제 되게 자신있게 파란
옷을 입고 왔잖아요. 그러고 나서
약간 후회되는 거예요. 아, 오늘은
약간 그래서 분명히 아침에 장을
>> 미국 장을 보고 아, 좋을 거
같은데. 음더힘내고
아주 야진 핑크색 짙은 핑크색을 입고
왔습니다네.
>> 아이 감사합니다. 그 제가 주식
시장에 있으면 어 펀드 매니저나
애널리스트들 중에서
>> 빨간 본펜만 쓰는 사람이 있어요.
네. 어 일부러 빨간 볼펜으로 써요.
어 뭐든지.
>> 그래서 제가 그때마다 이름은 빨간
걸로 쓰지 마라.
그런데도 꼭 쓰더라고. 예. 그런
빨간색을 또 좋아하는 시장 사람들이
또 있죠.
>> 네.
>> 네. 좋습니다. 저희 시장을 좀
볼까요?
>> 네. 분위기가 오늘도 나쁘지
않습니다. 시장 분위기 돌아보고 뉴스
체크해 보도록 하겠습니다. 어, 일단
코스피 지수 같은 경우는 현재
0.3% 3% 가량의 강세를
보여주면서 어제 600포인트 올려주고
오늘도 추가 상승이라고 저는 표현하고
싶습니다. 7,840선
현재 지나가고 있고요. 코스닥 같은
경우는 오늘 장중에 5% 넘게
오르기도 했었고요. 현재 같은 경우도
1159포인트 지나가면서 분위기 타고
가고 있습니다. 계속해서 걸리는 것은
솔직하게 말씀드리면 환율입니다.
1,510원까지 터치를 하면서 약간
불안한 것은 사실이고요. 근데 달러
인덱스가 오르고 N러 환율이 올라가고
있기 때문에 이게 내질적인
요인이라고만 말씀드릴 수는 없다는 거
체크하도록 하겠습니다. 뉴스 한
가지씩 열어 보시죠. 아, 오늘
코스피수 같은 경우는 강고합입니다만
코스닥 시수가 굉장히 좋습니다.
사이트가 오늘도 걸렸고요. 국민 성장
펀드 출시와 함께 지금 환호하고 있는
코스닥입니다.
두 번째로는 오늘 두산 에너빌리티 장
초반에 분위기가 좋았습니다. 현재
두산 에너빌리티는 3%대 강세
보이면서 11만 원 선 지나가고
있는데요. 오늘 사실 온사이트
발전이라는 키워드가 조금 강조가 되고
있습니다. 어떤 내용인지 뒤에서
자세하게 설명드리도록 하겠습니다. 세
번째로는 삼성전기 봐야겠습니다. 시총
6위를 어 잘 지켜 나가고 있습니다.
현재도 장중 사상 최고 거 같네요.
8% 이상의 강세로 130만 원 선
지켜 나가고 있는데요. 어떤 흐름들
내용들이 있는지 체크해 보도록
하겠습니다. 마지막으로는 오늘
금요일인만큼 마지막 주 중시 일정해
드리죠. 지금까지 정호의 머니
뉴스였습니다.
>> 네. 감사합니다. 그 시황하고 주요
뉴스를 정리해 봤는데요. 그 중에서
일단 핵심은 뭐 출발은 지수로부터가
볼까요? 네. 코스피 지수가 이제
소폭 상승으로 보여주고 있는데 뭐
어제 많이 올랐으니까 좀 이해되는
측면이 있어요.
>> 어제 600포인트를 넘게 올렸습니다.
장 막판 그냥 붙였잖아요. 사실
그래서 오늘 저는 아 살짝 쉬어도
싶었는데 어 약간 흔들리는 거 같더니
또 강보합으로 붙여내고 있습니다.
왜냐하면 어 삼성전자 같은 경우는
소폭 쉬어 갑니다만 하이닉스가 그래도
보합권의 흐름들 현대차가 조금 빠지긴
합니다만 그래도 시총 5위단 안에서
어제 올린 거에 비하면 낙폭이 크지
않기 때문으로 해석할 수 있을 것
같고요. 그리고 오늘장의 특징이라고
한다면 상승 종목수가 많습니다.
코스피에서. 아, 너무 되게 좋은
현상인 거잖아요. 현재 코스피
시장에서 오르는 종목이 760개가
넘어가고 있고요. 뭐 코스닥기아
말할게 뭐 말할 필요 없이 상승하는
종목수 1400개 넘어가고 있습니다.
그래서 코스피 분위기는 적당히 잘
흘러가고 있다 보면 되겠고 한 가지만
추가해 드리면 기관이 오늘도 코스피를
삽니다. 오그랄 연속으로 매수하고
있고요. 오늘도 장중에는 연기금이
어쨌든간 사 주고는 있습니다. 음.
음, 코스닥 함께 바로 볼까요?
코스닥 같은 경우는 오늘 진짜
불기둥을 뽑네요. 4% 이상의 강세를
보여주고 있는데 뭐 여러 가지
이야기가 있습니다. 첫 번째로는 국민
성장 펀드 이거 효과 좀 보지 않겠냐
하는데
>> 진짜 있을까요? 어떻게 보세요?
>> 뭐 당연히 있다고 보고 있습니다.
네. 사실은 이제 제일 반가운 뉴스가
저는 오늘 코스닥 소식이에요.
>> 어, 코스피가 올라갈 동안 사실은
코스닥이 너무 많이 안 올라갔고요.
>> 안 올라가는 수준을 넘어서서 이제 좀
이제 실망
>> 음, 그리고 이제 체념, 체념 단계,
예, 포기. 예. 그 수준까지 가면은
사실은 나중에 이제 좋은 호재가
있거나 정부가 이제 시장을 자꾸
바꾸려고 하는데 그 타이밍을 넘어서면
그런 좋은 호재나 정책이 나와도 심폐
소생이 잘 안 될 수도 있는 단계까지
가면 아 큰 일인데라고 사실은 좀
걱정을 했는데요.
>> 아 중요한 정책적 호재 같은 것들이
오늘 이제 국민 정장 펀드 같은게
나와 주니까 어 약발은 반대
>> 그렇잖아요. 어느 단계를 넘어가면
주사를 놔도 안 되는데 어 약을
놓으니까 살아나고 약을 놓으니까
살아나네 그러면 아직 가능성이 있다는
거거든요.
>> 그래서 저 오늘의이 반등이 반가워요.
희망이 있다.
>> 그래서 코스닥에 오를 것 같은 이유
기대하는 이유 세 가지로 정리를 해
볼 수 있겠는데 어쨌든간 코스피를 좀
쫓아가긴 하잖아요. 완벽 완벽하게
분리가 되어 있지 않으니까. 어,
하반기의 증시 자체가 국내 증시
자체가 전반적으로 올라가면 코스닥도
좀 더 오르겠지가 첫 번째
이유였고요. 두 번째가 코스닥
프리미엄 지수 나오는 거. 네.
있었고 마지막으로는 연기금이랑 국민
성장 펀드 참여 확대 이런 것들
기대가 됐습니다. 그래서음
일단은 뭐 증시가 하반기에 오른다는
건 당연하고 국민 성장 펀드도 뭐
너무나 잘 팔려서 지금 완판이라고
하고 세 번째로 프리미엄 지수이
부분을 조금 더 보고 싶은데 코스닥
프리미엄 지수 출범을 하게 되면 어떤
효과가 있을까에 대해서 유한타
증권에서 코멘트 내놓은 거 함께
정리했습니다.
일본의 TSE 프라임 지수 구성
방법론과의 유사성에 따를 경우 코스닥
프리미엄 지수는 코스닥 대형 중형주군
내에서 적정 유동성 그리고 안정적인
지배 구조를 확보한 2년 연속 흑자
연간 순익 상위 10%에 해당하는
113개 종목 정도로 구성될 개성이
높아 보인다라고 분석했습니다.
>> 네. 음.
근데 그니까 코스닥에 대해서 우리가
이제 몇 가지 좀 고민해 볼 필요가
있는데요. 첫 번째는음 코스닥이 일단
그동안 코스피가 계속 상승하는데
>> 코스닥 상승률이 부진했고 심지어 뭐
하락한 느낌도 좀 있기 때문에 과연
반전이 있을까? 그런 차에서 저희가
어 좀 의미를 갖고 접근해 보는데
어 코스피가 주가가 오르는 이유하고
코스닥이 오르는 이유하고 다를 수
있다는 거예요. 그러니까 무슨
얘기냐면
>> 예를 들어서 코스닥의 대부분의
회사들은 이익이 막 엄청 급증하거나
단기간 내 엄청 좋아지거나 이런
회사들로 구성되 있지 않거든요. 물론
그런 회사들도 있지만 대부분 향후의
성장성을 기반으로 해서 지금 뭔가
열심히 하고 있는 회사들로 구성돼
있잖아요. 그래서 코스닥에 상장된
회사들을 평가하고 판단할 때
코스피하고 좀 다른 잣대로 판단해야
되는 측면이 있고 두 번째는 그런
측면에서
어 어 지금 이재명 정부가 추진하고
있는 방향성은 뭐냐면 어
자금이 그러니까 유동성이라고 하는
그러니까 일종의 자금이 부동산 말고
생산적인 부분으로 가야 된다는 얘기를
하고 있지 않습니까?
>> 네. 근데 그 생산적인 부분이라는게
어떤 의미냐면 어떤 회사에 자금이
들어가서 그 회사가 좋게 만드는 쉽게
말하면 그런 역할을 해야 된다는
거잖아요. 그런 역할을 하는데
코스닥은 가장 중요한 시장이요.
>> 네.
>> 그죠.
>> 의미가 있단 말이죠. 왜냐면 코스닥이
활성화가 돼야 새롭게 성장을 원하는
그리고 좋은 기술 쉽게 말해서 좋은
기술을 갖고 있는 회사들이 상장을
해서 거기에서 무의자로 자금을
조달해서 또 다른 성장을 만드는 그런
선순환을 만들 수 있다는 거죠. 네.
그래서 저는 코스닥이 활성화되기
위해서는 아까 이제 프리미엄 지수 등
얘기했지만 성장펀드도 얘기했지만
정책이 굉장히 중요하다.
>> 그런 정책이 그동안 좀 부제했다고 전
생각해요. 코스닥의 대상으로 한
정책들이 별로 없었던 거죠. 예를
들면 상법을 3차나 개정합니다.
그중에서 뭐 자사주를 소각한다는게 있
있었잖아요. 네.
>> 근데 코스닥 회사 중에서 자사주를
갖고 있는 회사가 누가 있어요? 다
코스피에 관련된 회사들이죠.
>> 그죠?
>> 그렇기 때문에 지금까지 주익 한국의
주익시장 정상화의 뭐 상법
개정이라든지 방법은 코스피에 좀
한정이 돼 있었는데 이제 앞으로는
코스닥 활성화를 위한 정책과 방향이
필요하지도 않냐.
>> 그런 차원에서 국민성장 펀드 그다음에
프리미엄 지수 어 이런 방향성은
유의하다라고 판단하고 있습니다.
>> 네. 그 이제 관 건다영커가 이제
코스닥 상상승의
이유를 세 가지로 말씀드렸잖아요.
제가 조금 더 구체적으로 설명드리면
저도 이거 다 동의하는 바고요. 예를
들어서 이제 코스피와 코스닥의 괴리율
이게 사실은 역사적으로 평균체가
있습니다. 그니까 예를 들어서
코스피가 2,000 몇 백이면
코스닥은 적어도 1, 몇백 예를
들어서 그러니까 아무리 무너져도 뭐
반 또는 60%까지는 따라가는
거예요.
따라오든
이런 느낌 최근에 이제 한 8,
9개월 사이에이 격차가 역사적 평균
계보다 확 벌어졌어요.
>> 그럼 코스피가 8,이에요. 내일모래.
음.
>> 근데 코스닥은 여전히 지금 천이에요.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 반발 바로 뒤에 따라오던 동생이
이제는 눈에 안 보일 정도로 저
뒤에가 있단 말이에요. 그러니까
우리가
어 역사적 평균 괴리올 쪽으로 어느
언젠가는 수렴하지 않겠느냐라고 하는
과거의 경험이 있다.요 말씀 해 주신
거고
>> 그게 항상 옳지 않더라도이 정도
궤류는 커도 너무 크다. 아 이거는
이상적 좀 비정상적이다.
붙는다. 이런 흐름을 좀 믿어보자.
이런 말씀이시고 저도 충분히 그렇게
보 봐도 좋다라고 봐요. 왜냐면 너무
많이 벌어졌어요. 예. 그다음에 두
번째가 근데 이제 내버려두면 동생이
항상 따라오는 건 아니잖아요. 따라갈
수 있게 밀뤄주고 형이 좀 기다려
주고 약간 요런게 필요한데 그게
>> 우유 우유를 줘야 줘. 그래야 클 거
>> 아니 그렇지. 그니까 이제 방금
이광수 대표님 말씀이에요. 어
내버로드도도 따라갔는데 좀 못 따라가
그러면 너 좀 밀뤄주기도 하고
영양제도 주고 힘내라고. 어,
박카스도 한병 요거를 이제 정부가 해
줘야 된다는 그런 말씀이신 거
같고요. 그다음에 두 번째가 지금
프리미엄 지수 얘기해 주셨는데요.
너무 좋은 얘긴 거 같아요. 왜냐면
저 일전은 저희가 소개해 드렸어요.
정부 정책이
일단 여러 개가 있는데 코스닥을 3부
리그로 나눈다라는 거예요. 1부
>> 우등생, 모범생, 2부 그냥 평범한
애들, 3부 퇴출 직전. 아, 태출
직전이라면 너무
딱지를 씌우는 거 같지만 나머지
공부해야 되. 애들 이런 애들 예
근데 그 1부 리그를 나누는 애들을
놓고 놓고 별도의 지수가 나올 수도
있다라는 거예요. 그러면 1부 리그가
얘네들은 1부 리그입니다라고 말하고
그래서 끝나면 어 내가 1부 리그
있는 애들만 찾아야지 하고 있는 개인
수급만 있을 수 있는데 그게 아니고
그 일부 리그 있는 애들을 가중
평균해서 1등은 뭐 5, 2등은 4
이렇게 해가지고 100개 애들을 딱이
가중 평균해서 지수를 만들고 그
지수가 만약에 제대로 런칭되면 그
지수를 추종하는 ETF라든지 별도
상품이 또 만들어지거든요. 그게 다시
수급으로 또 개별 지수를 사게 되는
효과.이 음효가 한번 우리가
>> 코스피 200, 코스닥 150 이런
어떤 대표 지수를 제외하고는 지수
관련해서 사실은 제대로 마케팅이 잘
안 되는 시장이에요. 왜냐면 그동안
만들어진 지수가
>> 별로 시장성이 없어요. 있는 지수랑
결 뭐 비슷하네라든지
어 그래서이 지수는 만약에 잘
골라진다면 한번 희망을 걸어 볼
만하다라는게 없게 조심스러운 기대인데
지금 이제 유한타 유한타 증권의
분석에 따르면
>> 일단은 안정적 지배 구조 그러니까 좀
장난치지 않는 애들 그리고 2년 연속
흑자 전 이게 중요하다고 보거든요.
코스닥 종목 중에서 사실은 예 돈 못
버는 애들이 많아요. 근데 때려
주여도 무너지지 않는 명분
실적입니다. 실적이 바탕이 되고 지배
고조가 바탕이 된다라는 건 뭐냐면 예
믿을 수 있는 회사 그리고 연간
순위익도 상위 10%에 해당하는
종목으로 만약에 뽑아진다면 이거는
진짜 잘 고른 모범생 지수니까이
지수가
>> 이제 하나의 이제 모멘텀이 돼서
ETF도 만들어지고 수급도 만들어지고
선수란도 만들어지고 그럼 그 지수에
있는 상품 또 개별적으로 믿고
투자해도 좋은 요런 흐름이
만들어진다.요 기대가 만약에
성공적으로 안착된다면 코스닥도 괜찮을
수 있다. 이런 생각하고요. 최근에
이제 제일 중요한게 연기금이 그동안
코스닥에 투자를 많이 안 했어요. 안
하는 이유가 뭐냐면
>> 하면 뭐해? 평가를 안 해 주는데
내가 이걸 투자해서 성과가 났다라는
평가 대상에 없어요. 코스닥이.
그러니까 해도 성과가 안 돼. 할
이유가 없어요. 그런데 이제 그
부분에 관해서 정부가 길을 좀
열어주고 연기 투자를 좀 활성화 해
주고 하면 좋은데 오늘도 연기금 이제
조금 들어온다고 하고 결정적으로 이제
국민 성장 펀드가 지금 성공적으로
런칭을 하면
>> 일반 국민들 국민 여러분한테 지금 런
오픈된게 6천억인데 그게 다가
아니고요. 투융자로 잡히는게 한
20조 되고요. 정부가 직접
투자하는게 한 7조 넘어가거든요. 그
돈이 아 6천억 나와 가지고 코스닥이
사는 거야. 그게 아니고요. 들어올
돈이 수십조예요. 그
>> 예. 어떤 회사는 이제 돈을 꺼져서
기술 개발해 하는 경우도 있고 어떤
회사는 우리 집은 직접 태울게라는
경우도 있고 그니까 정책 모멘텀에
가장 민감한게 코스닥인데 그야말로
정부가 돈을 확 풀어 가지고 제대로
해 보라고 키워 준다고 하니까 일단은
이런 어떤 그 믿을 수 있는 호재들이
되기 중이에요. 예. 네. 조희을
보셔도 좋다. 저는 그렇게 봐요.
>> 좋습니다. 그런 차원에서 저희가 이제
코스닥에 대해서 관심을 좀 가지실
필요가 있다는 판단이고요.
>> 그러면 이제 코스닥에 투자를 하고
싶다.
>> 음.
>> 그러면 제일 먼저 생각나는 거 일단
코스닥 ETF입니다.
>> 그죠? 코스닥은 150 ETF가 일단
있고
>> 그러면 150 ETF라는 건 주요
회사들로 구성돼 있고 뭐 대형
회사들로 있고 실적이라든지 이런 것도
감안된 거니까
>> 네. 그 관련해서도 최근에 뭐 새로
들었고 나간 회사들이 있다고 해요.
>> 오늘 발표가 됩니다. 오늘 마감하고
나서 코스닥 150 어 어떤 종목들로
다시 포함을 시킬지 발표가 되는데
이걸 리밸런싱이라는 표현을 씁니다.
그러니까 코스닥 그냥 시가 총액
1위부터 150위까지 순서를 세운
이게랑은 조금 달라요.
>> 네. 어 그래서 어 1평균 시가 총액
거래대금 데이터를 봤을 때음 너희들은
150등 안에 들 수 있겠어라고
이야기를 하고요. 그래서 만약 시가
총액이 원래 150이었는데 많이
떨어졌거나 아니면 거래가 많이 붙지
않거나 이런 종목들은 편출이라는
표현을 써서 뺍니다. 네.
>> 어 근데 그래서 이거를 6개월 단위로
한 번씩 체크를 해서 종목들을 발표를
하는데 그게 오늘 마감하고 나서 어
있고요. 음. 음. 그래서 어떤
종목들이 들어갈 수 있는지에 대해서
체크를 한번 해보.
>> 네. 예상입니다. 지금 제가 표를 한
가지 가져와 봤는데요. 예.
>> 아, 꼼꼼 건다요. 너무 궁금한 거
잘 갖고 오셨어요. 네. 코스닥
150의 편입 편출 예상 종목입니다.
여러분 예상입니다. 그리고 제가
빨간색 박스를 쳐 놨는데 그 빨간색
박스를 친 이유는 삼성증권, 유한타
증권, 미래세 세 증권사에서 모두
편입될 것 같다라고 이야기한
종목이에요. 어 그러면 가능성이 좀
높다라는 거겠죠. 네. 그래서
뭐홀딩스, 파두, 성호전자,
IT생글로벌,
현대부스, 세트레가이, 효림로봇,
표시멘트, 3현, 한라캐스트,
미래셀, 벤처 투자 같은 종목들을
지금 증권가에서는 150에 들어갈 수
있는 종목이다라고 이야기를 하고
있습니다.
>> 네. 그리고 이게 중요한게 코스닥
같은 경우는 말씀해 주신 대로
유동성이 적잖아요. 그래서 여기에
포함되거나 혹은 편출됐을 때 주가
괴리율이 꽤 큽니다. 코스피는 그렇지
않은데 코스닥이 그렇기 때문에 종목들
흐름 좀 체크해 보시면 좋겠네요.
>> 그러니까 뭐 갑자기 그렇지만 코스피와
코스닥이 뭐냐 이런
>> 네
>> 왜 웃어요? 아니 너무 근본적인
질문이에요.
>> 이렇게 궁금하실 거 같아 뭐 분도
계실 거 아니에요. 우리 함께 하면
한 명이라도 함께 갑니다.
>> 네. 아 일어나서 학교 가야지
그랬더니 어마 학교 꼭 가야 돼.
이런 질문을 갑자기 맞이하는 그런
느낌이에요.
>> 그렇죠 여러분. 근데 어렵지 않아요.
코스피는
>> 일단 큰 회사, 대학 회사, 뭐
이렇게 아는 회사라고 쉽게 생각하시고
>> 코스닥은 좀 중소용 회사 이렇게
간단하게 생각하시면 되고 이제 앞으로
성장 가능성이 있는 회사들을 모아놓은
주의 시장에서 모아놓은 어 시장이라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그런데 이제
새롭게 코스닥 150이라 그래서 어
쉽게 얘기하면 코스닥의 수많은 종목
중에서 그래도이 종목은 유동성도 있고
그리고 그 안에서도 나름대로 어
대형주야라고 이제 150을 선정하는데
자 코스닥을 내가 투자하고 싶다.
그러면 어떤 종목에 투자해야 됩니까?
>> 그니까 검증된 애들
>> 검증이 뭐예요?
잠깐 딴 생각했어요.
>> 왜 그러시?
>> 아니 댓글을 보고 있었거든요. 진짜
방금 저희 얘기에 대해서 너무
근본적인 질문에 무릎을 탁 치고
갑니다. 박시동 비유 천재 요걸 좀
보고 있었어요. 네.
>> 아니 고랭크 님 수많은 코스닥 종목이
있잖아요. 그래서 우리가 코스닥에
관심을 갖자 해서 이제 코스닥 ETF
뭐 투자하셔도 되는데 내가 개별
종목에도 관심을 좀 갖고 싶은데
그러면 그 종목 중에서도 뭔가를
선택해야 되지 않습니까? 그러면 그런
기준이 있을까요? 일단 코스닥에
상장된 종목이 거의 1800개이기
때문에 이게 진짜 중요하거든요.
>> 근데 결론적으로 개인 투자자분들,
우리 국민 투자자 여러분의 결론을
말씀을 드리자면 결국에는 지수
ETF를
>> 어 사게 되지 않았나라는 생각을
합니다. 말씀해 주신 대로 사실
실적으로 증명할 수 있는 회사가 몇
개 안 돼요. 어 그러다 보니까
기대감이라는 것으로 가야 하는데 아
이게 참 어려운 거란 말이죠. 혹나
개인 투자자 내가 혼자서 트레이딩하는
입장에서는 어렵기 때문에 아마 지수
관련 ETF를 많이 매수를 하셨고
주변에서도 어 코스닥은 어떻게 해야
돼? 지수 ETF 사면 돼. 그니까
이미 결론으로 나고 저한테 여쭤
보시더라고요.
>> 그니까 전 두 가지를 권유드리고
싶은데 이제 코스닥 ETF를 저희가
관심 갖고 투자를 시작하시는데
대신음 분할해 매수하셨으면 좋겠다.
꾸준하게 좀 길게 보시고 장기적으로
보시고 이걸 권유드리고 두 번째는
>> 종목을 설치 설 그니까 선택할 때
선택하실 수 있죠.
>> 네. 어, 근데 제가 잘 모를 때
가장 좋은 방법은 뭐냐면 따라하는
거예요. 음. 그래서 코스닥 종목
중에서도 아까 이제 연기금
얘기하셨잖아요. 국민연금이 지분을
갖고 있어요.
>> 네.
>> 그러면 조금 안심이 되죠. 근데 그
국민연금이 지분을 갖고 있는 종목
중에서도 최근에 지분율이 증가한
회사.
>> 예. 그런 회사들이 여러분 한번
보시면 아 나 이런 회사 한번 볼까
해서 어 사업 보고서를 보 아
그러니까 최근에 공시 사항을 보면 어
여러분 그러면은 어 국민연금이
지분율을 올린 회사면 뭔가 변화가
일어날 수 있거든요. 그리고 아까
말씀드린 것처럼 국민연금이 이제
코스닥을 비중을 늘린다고 하지
않습니까? 그러면 자기가 이미 갖고
있는
>> 종목을 더 사겠지
>> 새로 사진 않아요. 왜 그런지
아세요? 새로 살려면 공부를 해야
되거든. 그렇죠. 다 이걸 나 사야
돼요 하고 내야 되.
>> 어 퍼포트 써야 돼. 여러분 다
국민연금 거기도 다 공무원이요.
일하기 싫어요. 아니 뭐
>> 아니 일하기 싫 아니걸 떠나서 절차가
많죠. 우리 같으면 그냥 사가 되지만
국민연금 나 요거 요래서 요렇게
살게요. 그 오케이 받아야 되니까.
>> 그죠. 근데 굳이 시가 종약이 크지
않는 종목을 새로 내가 탐방 가고
리서치하고 보고서 쓰고 이거 사야
됩니다 할 이유가 별로 없다. 그러면
기존에 내가 비중을 갖고 있는 회사를
더 사는게 되게 쉽다.
>> 그래서 일단 가장 큰 그 기준은
국민연금이 코스타 그 종목에 여러분
관심 있는 종목에 국민연금이 지분을
갖고 있느냐
>> 한 발자국 더 나가서 최근에
증가했느냐를 보시면 좋으실 것
같습니다. 어떻습니까?너무 너무 좋은
꿀팁이고요. 틀릴이 일이 없는 완벽한
꿀팁입니다. 때는요.
>> 그렇죠. 나 이거 하기 시간 없다
그러면 그냥 ETF 산다. 근데
우리는이 얘기를 이미 했어요.
>> 왜니까
>> 우리 스타벅스 가지 말고
>> 코스닥 ETF 사자라고 말씀드렸어요,
안 드렸어요?
>> 이틀 전에만 샀어도. 그죠?
>> 네. 오늘 스타벅스 사진입니다.
어떻습니까? 아주 좋아요.
상태가 아주 좋아요. 여러분, 오늘
오후 정도에 저한테 재보가 온
사진이거든요. 저 지점이 아, 저
스타벅스가 평소에는 굉장히 분배던
곳이라고 해요. 근데 거의 비어 있지
않습니까? 아, 여러분 우리가 너무
잘해내고 있습니다. 그런데 아끼는
거에서 그치지 않고
>> 뭔가를 해하셔야 될 거 아닙니까?
그걸 뭐 뭘 하자? 코스닥 ETF
하자.이 말씀을 드렸습니다.
>> 네, 좋습니다. 네. 그리고 오늘
코스닥 아무튼 그 코스닥 150이라는
그 지수 예
>> 오늘 새로 들어올 예정인 예상인
종목들 이제 건당님 말씀해 주셨고
오늘부터 이제 빠질 수 있는 종목들
리스트도 좀 알려 드렸는데요. 그러면
이제 야 여기 들어오는 종목 어
15개 얘네들은 오늘 들어갈 건가 봐
그러면 이제 아까 말씀 코스닥
ETF가 얘네들을 이제 사게
되거든요. 예 그러면 수급이
좋아지겠네라고 하니까 무조건 난 미리
산다 요거는 조금 아닙니다. 냐면
>> 이
>> 아직 예상이니까 저녁에 끝나 봐야
되는 거고 그중에서도 예를 들면 제가
그냥 어느 기업은 얘기 안 할게요.
쑥 보니까 그냥 제 개인적으로
>> 너 같으면 살래?
살 수
>> 있겠어? 오늘 저녁에 들어간다면 그럼
다음 주부터 ETF가 사야 될 거
아니야? 아, ETF가 미래 알고
샀겠지. 뭐 이렇게 생각하시는 분들
계실까 봐,
>> 너 같으면 사겠어라고 물어보면 저
같으면
>> 두 종목 정도만 매력적으로 느껴져요.
>> 그러니까 여러분이 여기 들어간다
그래서 무조건 사야지. 요건
아니니까.
>> 요렇게 걸러진 애들을 놓고 한 번 더
검증해 보시라. 네. 그럽니다.
나머지 공부 반드시 필요합니다,
알겠습니다. 여러분들이 근데 뭐 좀
어렵게 생각하실 수 있어요. 예를
들어서 연금이 갖고 있는 종목은
어떻게 찾아요라고 하는데 어 그
방법은 어 간단하게만 우선 말씀드리면
전자공지 시스템에가 보시면 다트라고
합니다. DAR라고 해서 다트에
들어가시면 여러분들이 그 회사를
조회해 보시면 공시 사항이 쭉
나오거든요. 그중에서 국민연금이
공시한게 있나를 찾아보시면 돼요.
나중에 한번 이거를 시연하는 걸 한번
해 볼까 합니다. 연결해서 좋을 것
같아요. 그러니까
>> 다트 찾기 뭐 하다 못해 뭐
권당커님은 이제 뭐 어어 MTS나 뭐
이런 거 잘 보는 거 한번 저희가
해야
>> 되겠는데 없잖아요.
>> 아 너무 좋다. 네. 제작진들 지금
머리 아픈 소리 저것도 화면 어떻게
잡아야 되지 막 이러면서. 예.
그래서 좀 시간을 갖고 어 저희가
그런 것도 한번 여러분들하고 같이
해보도록 하겠습니다. 예. 좋습니다.
다음 뉴스로가 볼까요?
>> 네. 두 번째 뉴스는 지금 오늘
상승률 상위에 수소 관련주 그리고
가스 터빈 관련주 이런 것들이 좀
올라와 있어요. 근데 이게 우리나라만
그런게 아닐 아니라 전 세계적인
현상이어서 좀 가져와 봤습니다. 온
사이트 발전이라는 거 우리가 좀 알고
가야 될 거 같아서 준비를 해
봤습니다. 그니까 온 사이트 말
그대로 요기서 발전한다라고
설명을 할 수 있겠고요. 그니까
데이터 센터가 전기가 무조건
필요하잖아요. 근데 외부 전력망에
의존하지 않고 그 온 사이트 현장에서
독립적으로 전력을 생산해서 전력 부족
지연 문제를 해결하려는 방식입니다.
어 우리나라에서는 아직까지 조금
어렵기는 한데 해외에서는 지금 이거를
굉장히 열심히 하고 있어요. 그래서
해외 어떤 뭐 많이들 들어보셨을
종목은이 온사이트 발전이라고 해서 어
하는 것들을 만들고 있는데 요즘
주가가 굉장히 좋은데 그 이유 자체가
발주가 엄청 많이 나와요.
>> 그러니까 전 세계에 데이터 센터를
깔아야는데 전기가 없으니까. 근데
전기를 가져오려면 우리가 전력 망도
깔아야 되죠.
가져야 되는게 많으니까 이거 허가도
받아야 되고 그러니까 최소 3년이라고
이야기를 하거든요. 근데 데이터센터
어떻게 3년 기다려요? 네. 그러다
보니까이 온사이트 발전이라는 것이
지금 주목을 받기 시작했다라고
알고 계시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
그래서 온사이트 발전원이라는게
있어요. 그래서 뭐 중속 엔진,
Sc형
가스 터빈네 가지가 있는데
>> 네
>> 좀 어려워요.
>> 아니요. 너무 좋은 지금 세마를
설명해 주시는 거예요. 자세히 살셔도
좋을 것 같아요. 중속 엔진은 우리
조선의 국모 엄경아 애널리스트 저희
모셨을 때이 이야기를 했어요.
>> 맞아요.
>> 어, 조선 엔진이 왜 AI야라고 했을
때 조선사들이 엔진을 만들잖아요.
근데 추진 엔진을 만들기도 하고
거기다 발전 엔진을 만들기도 합니다.
왜냐면 배 안에서 전기 써야 되니까.
그래서이 발전 엔진이 중속 엔진이라고
보시면 됩니다. 근데 말씀드렸던 대로
지금 여기서 당장 전기 만들어야 돼
했을 때 딱 필요한게 중속 엔진이라는
겁니다. 그래서 대용량으로 단기
전력란을 쓰이는 엔진이고요. 그래서
우리나라에서는 HD 현대중공업이 하고
있습니다. 피크 대응력이 굉장히
높지만음
데이터 센터 피크 어 대응력이 높아서
데이터 센터의 적합도가 높다라고
하고요. SC라는게 있어요. 이것도
저도 좀 어려운데 고체산화물
연료전지라는
겁니다. 쉽게 설명을 드리면 고온에서
고효율로 전기를 뽑아내는 연료
전지다라고 설명할 수 있고요. 수소,
천연 가스, 바이오가스, 암모니아
이런 것들을 사용할 수 있어서
친환경에 가깝다라고
써 있죠. 그래서 우리나라에서는
두산월셀이 있고요. 지금 그 앞에
블룸 에너지라고 영어로 써 있는데
우리나라 상장주 중에이 블룸 에너지에
납품하는 회사들이 있습니다.이
회사들이 요즘 날아가고 있어요.
>> 음.
>> SFC가 또 어 주목을 받는 이유는
전기 효율이 나머지네 개 중에 제일
높아요.
>> 말 그대로 효율이 높다는 거. 온도가
워낙 고압이기 때문에 효율이 높고 어
대신 단점이 있다면 케펙스 부분이
높음으로 돼 있잖아요. 그 좀
비싸요. 어 비싸지만
>> 장점이라면 데이터 센터에 적합하고
도심 입지에 굉장히 적합하다.
>> 네.
>> 페스라는 건 투자를 말하는 거예요.
>> 네. 투자. 네. 예,
보시면 됩니다. 그다음에 Pc라고
한다면 인산형 연료전지라고
합니다. 그래서 인산을 전해질로 쓰는
연료 전지고요. 온도가 SFC보다는
낮아요. 그래서 SOFC가 제가
알기로는 막 1,000도 이렇게
가는데 어 PAC 같은 경우는 뭐
120도이 정도로 알고 있습니다.
그래서 약간 전기 효율은 낮지만
그래도 어
긍정적으로 워낙 지금 전기를 끌어오는
모든게 중요하기 때문에 다 쓴다라고
보시면 됩니다. 마지막으로는 소형
가스 터빈인데 말 그대로 가스 터빈,
가스 붙여서 전기 만드는 거다라고
보시면 되겠고 요거 두산 퓨열셀에서는
대형 가스 터빈 하고 있긴 한데 여튼
이렇게 다양한 온사이트 발전원들이
지금 주목을 받고 있고 관련된
종목들이 엄청나게 날아가고 있다.
이렇게 보시면 됩니다.
>> 그러니까 AI 데이터 센터를 만드는데
전력이 가장 큰 문제지 않습니까?
전력을 워낙 많이 쓰니까. 음전을는
방이 기존의 발전소에서 송배전설비를
통해서 받는 방법이 있고 근데 그게
너무 부족하니까 이제 데이터 센터를
지으면서 내가 그냥 발전소를 옆에
지을게 바로 그게 저 모델이거든요.
네.
>> 어 이건 뭐냐면 쉽게 말하면 이런
거죠. 과거에 내가 내 집 옆에 다
발전소 하나씩 만들고 내가 필요한
전기를 거기서 받아쓰고 지금 그렇게
하겠다는 거잖아요.
>> 네. 어 그래서 저건음 기본적으로
AI 데이터 센터를 투자하는데 또
금액을 올리기도 하고 굉장히 필수
설비로 각광을 받는 거 같아요.
>> 네. 음,
>> 실제로 미국에서 AI 데이터 센터를
부지를 지을 때 사업 진행하는
사람들한테 뭐가 1순이야라고 물어봤을
때 1번은 전력입니다.
>> 맞습니다.
>> 그러니까 어 좀
>> 크게 보면 이런 거예요. 지금 어
증시가 좋아. 그래, 나도 투자하고
싶어. 그러면 뭐 사야 돼라고 할 때
>> 사람들이 바글바글한데 사람들이 막
살려고 어 줄서 있는 그 주식을
먼저가 봐. 우리가 이렇게
얘기하잖아요. 그럼 거기가 어딘데라고
쫙가 보면 거기가 어디냐면 AI
백화점이라고 보시면 돼요. 그
백화점에 사람들이 다 줄을서 있어요.
여기서 물건 사야 돼 막 그러고
있어요. 그러면 AI 백화점에 딱
들어가 보면 뭐가 있냐면 AI
생태계의 처음부터 끝까지의 공급망에
걸려 있는 것들은 다 지금 사람들이
줄서 있다. 이렇게 보시면 돼요,
여러분. 근데 그게 뭔데라고 보면
예를 들면 1층에 반도체가 있는
거죠. 음일이든 우재
이런 거 리려면 뭐론도 하고 뭐 해야
된데 그러려면 결국 반도체가
필요하돼.
>> 어 그래 알았어. 그니까 1층에
반도체가 있는 거고
>> 그럼 반도체만 사고 살려고 봤더니
그게 아닌 거죠. 이제 그런 식으로이
>> 데이터이 반도체가 꼽혀 있는 데는
어디냐 봤더니 데이터 센터야. 그럼
누가 데이터 센터 짓냐? 짓는 애들
예를 들어서 그다음에 거기 전기 누가
넣어야 될 거 아니야? 안 그러면 안
돌아가잖아. 전기 뭐 이런 식으로
AI 전체 생태기 안에서 공급망 체인
안에 하나씩 딱 딱 딱 길목을 잡고
있는 애들은 지금 괜찮다.
>> 네.
>> 이렇게 보면 그중에서도 이제 한 섹터
안으로 쭉 들어갔더니 전기
>> 전기를 만들어야 돼. 전력이죠. 그
전력 중에서 멀리서 당겨오는 뭐
원전도 좋고 신재생도 좋고 다 좋은데
언제 기다리냐?
>> 어 당장 데이터 센터 옆에다 그냥
당장 갖다 붙여 가지고 일단 필요한
거만 쓱쓱 만들어라고 하면
얘네들이네. 네. 지금 이것 전체
안에서 하나의 병으로 자리할 수 있을
것 같다라고 해서 이제 관심이
높아지고 있는 건데
>> 그런 어떤 중요한
>> 유행을
이제 권당코님이 갖고 오신 거고 다소
어려운 공부일 수도 있습니다만
>> 빨발 발빠른 사람들은 이미 다
공부하고 거기가 지금 줄서 가지고
번호표 끊고 있으니까 우리
독자님들도이 참여 아셔야 된다 이런
얘기죠. 요거는 저희가 뭐 계속해서
공부를 좀 해 보도록 하고요. 네.
제가 관심 있는 건 그거예요. 그니까
AI라는 거대한 그니까 새로운 시대가
열리고 있는데 과거에 이런 거죠.
미국에서 골드러시가 일어납니다.
>> 그래서 다 캘리포니아나 뭐 LA나
이런데 금캐러 가잖아요.
>> 네.
>> 근데 금캐 막상 금캐러 간 사람들은
돈을 번게 아니라 리바이스가 돈을
벌지 않습니까?
>> 그렇죠. 곡이
>> 그래서 제가 관심이 있는 건 과연
AI 시대가 왔을 때 누가 리바이스가
될 건지가 전 관심이 있어요.
>> 네.
>> 그게 과연 뭘까? 그러니까 분분한
거죠. 그게 뭐 반도체다, 뭐 뭐
뭐다, 뭐다 얘기 있는데 결국엔 그
답을 뭔가 찾아야 되지 않을까? 네.
>> 그런 그런 지향을 갖고 누가
지속적으로 누가 가장 중요한 건지
>> 그런 고민을 좀 해 볼 필요가 있어
보입니다.
>> 맞습니다. 그래서 저희가 지난주에
소개해 드린 것도 좀 예리하게 보시면
>> 현대중공업 조선하냐?
이렇게만 알고 계시면 이제 벌써 옛날
투자자가 되시는 거고 걔네들이 만드는
엔진이
>> 발전원이 돼 가지고 데이터 센터
옆에도 들어갈 수 있단 말이야.
>> 음.
>> 에이, 설마 말이 되겠어? 아니 이미
발조가 나왔는데요.
>> 이러면서 현대가 만든 엔진이 뭔데?
힘센 엔진이라고 있어요.
>> 그럼 얘네 조선 회사야? 이제 AI
회사야.
>> 그렇죠.
>> A 회사라고 봐도 됩니다라는 얘기를
하 사람들이 하기 시작했다. 이런
얘기거든요. 예. 요런 이제 포인트를
아셔야 된다라는게 또 권다용 생각
아니겠습니까?
>> 알겠습니다. 관련해서 세 번째 뉴스도
연관이 되는 거죠. 그래서 삼성전기에
관련된 이슈인데 그걸 네.
현재는 129만원선
지나갑니다. 아 일단
>> 삼성전기를
포함한 커패시터 시장이 아마 청바지가
되지 않겠냐라는 그런 이야기들이
나오고 있습니다.
>> 예. 삼성전기 지금 목표 주가가
160만 원에서 제일 높은 수준으로
나온게 한 170만 원까지가 있다고
일단 보도록 하겠고
>> 네. 지금 현재 주가가 120만 원
선인데 130만 원 다 와가는데
추가적으로 목표가는 160 170까지
지금 올라가 있다.
>> 네. 맞습니다. 그게 어제 나온
리포트 가격이고요.
>> 왜요?
>> 왜 그러냐는 일단 모건 스탠리의
분석으로부터 시작을 합니다. 이게
이것도 스토리가 여러분 좀 길어요.
집중해서 들어 주시면 됩니다.
엔비디아가 실적을 발표했잖아요.
그러면서음 우리 베라루빈 잘 만들
거야. 루빈치 되게 좋다. 우리
3분기부터 만든다. 근데 비싸라는
이야기를 합니다. 그래서 모건
스탠리에서 이걸 까보 시작한 거예요.
음. 뭐가 얼마가 들어가나. 그래서
엔비디아 차세대 모델의 원가를
분석했습니다.이
표가 아시아 시장 다 돌면서 지금
아시아 시장에 있는 모든 메모리,
PCB, AFP, 아, ABP,
MLCC 가격 지금 관련된 종목들이
날아가고 있습니다. 다 영어로 돼
있어서 조금 어렵잖아요.
>> 그러니까 한번 볼까요? 저기서 GB
300이라는 건 과거 모델이고
>> 네.
>> VR200이라는 건 새롭게 지금
만들고 있는 모델인데 비교에서 과연
금액이 더 커지는 건 앞으로
매출이라든가 그 산업이 커질 거라를
의미한다. 그래서 투자자들이 이제
관심을 갖는 거죠. 맞습니다. 어,
그래서 가장 큰 건 제가 일부러
빨간색으로 색칠를 해 왔어요. 뭐
배모리 가격입니다. 어쩔 수 없어요.
400% 이상의
>> 400%
>> 아 400%가 더 많이 든다
이거네요.
>> 네. 네. 가격이 원가가 400%
늘었다.
>> 네.
>> PCB 같은 경우도 지금 233%
늘었다.
>> 네. 그렇네요.
>> MLCC도 지금 182%
늘었다.
>> 이게 또 중요한 포인트 세 가지가
돼서 지금도 어제부터 대만, 일본,
우리나라 관련주들이 난리 법석도
아닙니다. 그래서 도대체 삼성전기가
하는 그 MLCC 커페시터가 뭔데부터
설명을 드릴게요. 패시터란
물리적으로 전기 에너지를 저장하는
장치로 배터리보다 저장 시간이 짧지만
빠른 충방전이 가능하다. 그래서
아키텍처들의 전력 효율 개선의
핵심으로 종류로는 MLCC, 슈퍼캡,
필름 컵패시더 등이 있습니다.
그러니까 쉽게 이야기를 하면 우리
전구 갈 때 그 옆에 뭐가 이렇게
볼록 튀어나온 거 하나 있잖아요.
그게 커패시터입니다. 잠깐 전기를
저장을 해서 그 스위치가 켜지고 꺼질
때 채워준다라고 생각을 해보시면
>> 그 전구 끝에 있는 거시터고
커패시터의 종류 중에 하나가
MLCC라고
보면 됩니다. 어 MLCC라고
이야기를 하는 이유는 근데 우리가
커페시터는 잘 들어보신 적이
없잖아요. 커패시터 전체 시장에서
거의 90% 정도가 MLCC입니다.
적층 세라믹 콘덴서라고
표현할 수 있겠습니다. 어 그러면은
뭐 MLCC 왜 뭐 이렇게 말씀하실
수 있잖아요. MLCC라는게
데이터 센터에 정말 많이 들어갑니다.
왜냐면 그전에도 말씀드렸지만 CPU,
GPU가 전기를 끊기지 않고
안정적으로 공급을 받아야 되는데
전기라는게 또 그렇지가 않잖아요.
그래서 그 중간 역할을 해 주는게
MLCC라서 고성능 MLCC가 데이터
센터에 어마어마하게 많이 들어갑니다.
근데 여기서 삼성전기에게 어 주가에
불을 붙여 준 공시가 하나 더
있었는데요. 실리콘 컴패시터라는 것을
수주하게 됐습니다.
>> 네. 지금 1조 5,억 원 규모의
실리콘 커패시터 공급 계약을
체결한했는데요.
실리콘 커패시터는 또 뭐냐라고 한다면
적층 세라믹 콘데서 그러니까
MLCC보다 더 얇아요.
>> 더 고성능이에요. 음.
>> 그래서 어 더 좋은 거를 수주받았네.
음.
>> 그래서 가격을 비교해봤더니
>> 기본 MLCC 대비 평균 판매 단가가
10배 이상으로 책정될 수 있다.
이런 이야기가 나오고 있습니다.
그래서
>> 이제 실리콘이 훨씬 더 얇을 거
아니에요. 세라믹보다 얇으면 칩 안에
임베디드라는 표현을 씁니다. 칩 안에
같이 넣어서 이제 어 세팅을 할 수
있기 때문에 이제는 빅테크들이 오
이제는 MLCC 그냥 쓰지 말고
실리콘 쪽으로 가야겠다라고
자리를 잡고 있다라고 보시면
되겠습니다.
>> 네. 상당히 어려운 얘기죠. 예.
조사 백원는 다 영어였어요. 이게
문제야.
>> 그러니까 이게 여러분들이 이제 이런
얘기를 하면 야 뭔 소리를 하냐?
>> 모르는 거야.
>> 그러니까 이게 주식 투자 참 어렵네.
네. 이렇게 하시는데 자네.
>> 예. 쉽게 쉽게 그냥 딱 정리해
드릴게요. 어려운 개념은 어차피
공부를 하셔야 되고요. 근데 우리가
이걸 왜 얘기하냐면 지금 오늘 다루는
맥락이 다
>> 전개
>> 다 똑같은 얘기예요. 예. AI
안에서 소위 말하는 병목 내가 목
잡고 있어. 병목의 목이면 되게
상스러운 표현이 아니고요. 내가 딱
목을 잡고 있기 때문에 나를 통과하지
않으면 안 돼.
에서 내야 하는 애들이 결국에는 지금
날아가고 있는데 반도체에만 날아가는
줄 알았더니 아니야. 가만히 보니까
아까 우리가 얘기했죠. 전력도
병목이네라고 한 거고 반도체 안에
보니까 거기 안에 다양한 기술들이
들어가 있는데 보니까
>> 얘네 얘네 얘네들도 보니까
병목이네라고 하는 주요 테마가 있는데
사실은 권당님이 지금 잘
짚어오셨는데요.
>> 우리가 지금 한 3, 4일 계속
조정을 받았잖아요.
>> 그리고 이제 어제 이제 겨우 쫙
하면서 이제 짠 하고 올라갔는데 우리
조정받을 때 대만이나 일본에서
생각보다 안 빠지고 날아간 종목들이
있어요. 그 뭐지라고 사실은 보신
분들은 몇 분 계실 텐데 다
얘네들이에요.
>> 그죠? 얘네들이 이미 날아가고
있었습니다.
>> 우라타 다이오유
>> 맞아요. 그러니까 상대적으로 우리
이제 우리나라 업체와 경쟁하고 있는
애들은
>> 그러거나 말거나 지금 날아가고 있단
말이에요. 근데 우리는 어 하면서
이제 덩달아 조정받으면서 지금 우리가
지금 잠깐 얘기하고 있는 삼성전지
같은 경우도 100만 원 밑으로
떨어졌었거든요. 근데 지금 경쟁
업체들은 지금 다 날아가고
있는데맞라고
>> 해서 어 곧 날아갈 게야 정상 아니야
이렇게 보고 있는 거였죠.
>> 쟤네만 갈 순 없잖아요. 우리도
가야죠.
>> 네. 그런데 어제 이제 반등을 했고
시장 전체가 반등을 하면서 같이 쭉
반등을 했는데이
>> 뭐 호사담 아니 뭐지?
>> 좋은 일이 좋은 일이 더 있다.
뭡니까? 이거 호사담 아닌 거
>> 기억 안 나요. 아무튼 갑자 아 배운
사람인데 생각이 안 나네. 아무튼요.
어제 요즘 사자성화
>> 어 쭉 반등하는데 어저께 어마어마한
호재가 나온 거예요. 우리 1조
>> 5천억짜리 계약 따냈습니다.
>> 수주를 했
>> 수주를 했습니다. 그러니까
>> 날아가고 싶은 데다가 이제 더 뒤에서
밀어주는 발음까지 불어주는 상황이
돼서 어제 날아간 거예요. 그리고
오늘 한 방 더 터진 거예요.
>> 음. 그게 지금 뭐냐면 여러분 이게
지금 투자에서 우리 이제 주식
아가분들도 많고 처음 오시는 분들
많은데 이게 지금 최첨단 유행이기
때문에맞
>> 다뤄드리는 거서 어저께 그 호재는
뭐야 난리났고 오늘 이건 뭐야라고
했는데 권행커님 갖고 오신 얘기 지금
세계적으로 날린 겁니다.
>> 네. NBD 어제 실적 좋았다고
이렇게 말씀드렸는데 모건 세트는
얘들을 딱 까본 거예요. 쫙 봤더니
야 이거네.
>> 여기 다 병목이네라고 했더니 병목
체크해 가지고 지금 또 아까 말씀드린
것처럼 일본 업체 대만 업체 오늘 또
날아가요.
>> 맞아요.
>> 그래서 일본 주가가 엄청 오르고
있습니다.
>> 예. 그런데 우리는 뭐야라고 봤더니
우리도 MLCC 있어. 또 MLCC
관련주들 있어. 이렇게 보는 거죠.
네.
몇 개 더 있긴 한데요. 어쨌거나
그래서
>> AI 병모 안에 들어 있는 회사들,
세계적으로 수주하는 회사들 얘네들에
관해서 지금 유행이 이렇게 오고
있다. 이런 얘기를 좀 해 드리는
거예요. 네.
>> 네. 그래서 뭐 아 뭔지는 알고 좀
투자를 하고 싶잖아요. 사람 마음이
어렵다.
>> 아니 근데 그래서
>> 아니 이걸 꼭 알아야 됩니까?
>> 어 근데 메모리가 얼마나 쓰이는지에
대해서는 이미 공부 다 하시지
않았을까요?
여분들께서
그죠? 그죠? 어 그다음이라고
하니까. 근데
>> 어 여러분 여러분들이 우리가 이런
이제 생소한 거를 접할 때 그러셨으면
좋겠어요.
>> 이게 어려운 건 아닌 거 같아요.
>> 아 그렇죠. 생소한 거예요. 처음
들어봐서
>> 어 좀 뭐랄까 어렵게 느껴져요.
>> 그런데 자꾸 듣다 보면 자꾸 듣다
보면 익숙해지고
>> 어
>> 쉽게 느껴질 수 있다고 저
생각합니다.
>> 맞아요.
>> 우리가 언제부터 뭐 시스템 반도체
이런 거 알았어요. 네.
>> 뭔데 어 자꾸 듣다 보니까
>> 듣다 보니까 익숙해지고 어 편해
편안해지는 거죠. 음.
>> 그래서 저희가 아여러분들 좀 이런
기드리면 이해 수도 있는데 그럼에도
불구하고 이야기를 한번 해드린
겁니다.
>> 왜냐면 오늘 이거는 전 세계 아시아
우리나라 시장에서는 이건 아셔야 되는
유행어 같은 거기 때문에 테마기
때문에 아셔야 됩니다.
>> 맞아요. 그래서 다음 시간에는요.요
관련돼서 좀 더 쉽게 정리한 뭐 용어
지비라고 할까? 그런 것들을 한번
제가 만들어
>> 드릴게요. 제작진 지금 바쁘거든요.
왜 자꾸 방송만 하면 출제를 주냐?
지금 쓰러지셨는데 미니님
>> 근데 전 이게 투자의에
장점이라고 봅니다.
>> 그럼요.
>> 뭐냐면 이런 과정을 통해서 우리가
뭔가 또 새로운 걸 배우게 되고
그리고 조금 더 세상에 관심을 갖게
되잖아요.
>> 플러스
>> 이게 또 투자에는 흐름이라는게
있잖아요.
>> 그럼요.
>> 어 메모리가 좋았어. 그다음에
MLCC야. 그다음이 넘어갈 때이
앞에 걸 모르면 약간 이해하기가
어려울 수 있어요.
>> 네. 네. 알겠습니다. 여러분, 약간
어려울 수 있었는데
>> 괜찮으신가 모르겠어요.
>> 예. 괜찮으신 거죠? 예. 근데 계속
한번 해 보도록 할게요.
>> 맞아요. 근데 진짜로 이광 대표님
말씀이 딱 맞아요. 어려운게
아니에요. 생소한 거예요. 근데
여러분이 반도체를
>> 먹고 씹고 느끼고 만진 적이 없어서
그런 거지. 이걸 빵이라고 생각하면은
쉬워요.
>> 빵만 회사가 인기.
근를 쓰네 결라는 회사에서 버터를
쓰네 그럼 급방이 잘 팔리면
버터애들도 나쁜 많이 하겠네 그런
식으로 번져가는 거 중에서
>> 아까는 버터 얘기한 거고 오늘은
밀가루 얘기하는 거고 이제 효모
얘기하는 거예요.
>> 아 근데 우리가 뭐 언제부터 헌법
같은 거 알았습니까? 근데 막 내란
일어나고 그러니까 헌법도 공부하게
되고 아 탄핵은 이렇게 하는 거구나
2분의 찬성에 뭐 이런 거 알게
되잖아요.
>> 그러니까
>> 어 하게 되면 닥치면
>> 다 안다.
>> 배운다.
>> 그리고 여러분 이게 너무 쉬운
거예요. 왜냐면
>> 진짜 그거를 현장에서 만드는 그 회사
>> 거기 다니는 연구원 그걸 만들어야
되는 사람은 따로 있잖아요. 이런
말씀드리면 뭐하지만 이게 주식 투자의
매력이에요. 그 사람들은 그렇게 일을
하라고.
>> 근데 성과가 좋아. 나는 주식을
살게.
>> 아 그렇죠. 너무 마지막 단에서
가볍게 수익을 볼 수 있는 거거든요.
쉽다. 내가 할 수 있는 일은 작다.
근데 수익은 크다. 이렇게 편안하게
생각하시.
>> 그리고 또 하나 말씀드리고 싶은 건
뭐냐면 많이 안다고 수익률이 높은게
아니에요.
>> 그 기본만 알면 돼요. 예를 들어서
삼성전기 다니는 사람 삼성전기 많이
갖고 있을 것 같으세요?
>> 주가 주식 없을 걸.
>> 아 근데 진짜 정답이야. 그니까 뭐
하는지 정도 어항이 좋네. 이런
정도만 아셔도 네. 주식은 아까
말씀드린 것처럼 쫓아가면 충분하다.
근데 쫓아가는데도
>> 방향을 알고 쫓아가야 될 거 아니에
누구 달려가는데 세 명이 달려가.
근데 그중에서 아 1등은 쫓아가야 될
거 아닙니까? 근데 막 엄한 사람
쫓아가면
>> 막 산길 가는 거예요. 힘든 길을
가는 거예요. 쉬운 길로 가기
위해서는 아 누가 이렇게 잘 달리고
있지? 아 속도가 어느 정도 가지?
요런 느낌을 아는 정도. 네. 저희가
계속해도 하겠습니다. 이런 기는
흥미없고요. 여러분들이 어렵게 생지
마시고 어 따라와주세요. 알겠습니다.
>> 마지막 뉴스로가 볼까요?
>> 네. 마지막은 이번 주 일정 보도록
하죠. 일단 월요일은 우리나라 홍콩
그리고 영국 미국 모두 휴장입니다.
>> 아 네. 석탄 한신일 저렇게 전
세계가 기념하네요.
>> 네.
화요일 같은 경우는 미국에서만 일적이
좀 있어요. 5월 컨퍼런스 보드
소비자 신뢰 지수입니다. 이걸 제가
써 놓은 이유는 미국에서도 지금
휘발류가 비싸 가지고 소비자 센티
그러니까 실 그 어 소비자들의 소비
여력이 그렇게 크지 않다라고 이야기가
나오는만큼 체크해 보도록 하겠고 또
이번 주에 미국 국채 입찰이 좀
있더라고요.
>> 근데 지금 금리 저희가 한 지난주부터
계속 얘기를 한 거 같아요. 네물이
화요일이
수요일입니다. 그고 5월 27일
삼성전자와 SK 하이닉스의 레버리지
ETF 출시될 예정입니다. 나입니다네
>> 그리고 목요일이 되면 한국은행
금융통화 위원회에서 금리를 결정하게
되는데요. 우리 신임총제인 신현송
총재의 대비일입니다.
어, 그리고 미국에서는 PC 물가
지수가 발표되는데 물가도 저희가
말씀드렸죠. 계속 높아지고 있기
때문에 추세가 어떤지 보도록
하겠고요. 음. 금요일에는 어, 4월
우리나라의 소매 판매 산업 생산
발표되고 미국에서는 임상종향 학회
시작되는데 우리나라 업체들도 사실 좀
관심이 크진 않지만 일단은 어, 뭐
참여하는 곳들이 있거든요.
>> 그럼요. 바이업계에서는 또 중요한
행사니까요.
>> 네.
그리고 MSC밸런싱데
이날부터 시작된다는
근데 전반적으로 비교해서 이제 실적
시즌이 끝나고 뉴스가 좀 적어지는
느낌이에요. 그래서 제가 생각하는 건
어 개별 일정에 대한 어떤 주식
시장의 변동성은 좀 줄어들 거 같고
다시 미국의 금리 추세라든가 아니면
유가 이런 어떤 거시 경제 변수에
주식 시장이 연동될 가능성이 좀
커버입니다.
>> 네. 한 가지만 여기서 더 붙여
드리고 싶은 건 MSC 분기 리뷰
결과는 나왔고요. 금요일부터 이제 어
이렇게 이렇게 바꾸자라고 발표했으니까
바꾼 상태로 진행이 됩니다. 근데
이번에 MSCI 코리아 지수에서 신규
편입 종목이 없었어요. 그러면서
삼성전자 SK 하이닉스의 유동
주식수가 상향 조정됐습니다. 그러니까
더 담겠다라는 거죠. 어, 지금
예상되는 그 정도는 5월 29일
종가에 SK 하이닉스는 9,700억
원, 삼성전자로는 4,400억 원의
자금이 더 유입될 가능성이 있다라는
분석들 나옵니다.
>> 네. 네. 오늘 뉴스를 정리해
봤고요. 시장을 좀 볼까요?
>> 네. 현재 코스피는 0.2%대 2%대
강세로 7,833포인트
지나가고 있습니다. 외국인은 어 1조
5,억 원대 매도하고 있고요. 개인이
1조원대 넘게 매수하고 있습니다.
기관에서 사고 있는데요. 오늘까지
하면 금융 투자에서 오거래일 연속
매수. 아, 연기금이 근데 저 이거
한 마디만 좀 하고 싶은데 장중에
연기금이 사고요. 마감할 때 꼭
코스피를 팔더라고요. 그래서 그건 좀
슬
>> 연금이요.
>> 장 끝날 때. 그러니까 장 중에는
매수로 잡히다가이 매수 규물을 조금씩
줄여면서 마감이 되는 경우가
많습니다. 그래서 그거 조금 속상해서
말씀드리고 싶고요. 오늘 분위기 좋은
코스닥 같은 경우는 5%까지 다시
상승폭 키웁니다. 1162포인트
지나가면서 5.1% 이상의 강세 보여
주고 있습니다. 외국인과 기관 모두
코스닥을 매수하면서 긍정적인 흐름들
나타나고 있고요. 에코프로비M이
11% 급등, 에코프로도 11%,
알테오젠 5%, 오, 주성
엔지니어링이 시총 4위 됐군요.
11%대 급등하고 있습니다.
>> 네, 감사합니다. 뉴스를 정리해
봤고요. 어, 이제 두 번째에
코너로가 보도록 하겠습니다.
예, 여러분, 금요일 12시에
만나요. 계속해서 이어나가겠습니다.
이번에는 생각을 나누는 시간인데요.
오늘은 광수 생각을 먼저 이야기해
보도록 하겠습니다.
최근에음
서울경제T가 어 유튜브에서 저런
내용에 방송을 합니다. 중국인이 강남
아파트를 기수했고 물량을 싹쓸리하고
있다. 어 보시면 어 뭐 구체적인
수치도 나와요. 강남 아파트를
944채를 사서 중국인들이 엄청나게
산다. 저 내용은 결국 무슨
얘기냐면음
최근에 강남의 아파트 즉 다주택자
규제를 해서 다주택자 양도세가 다시
부활되면서 다주택자들이 강남 지역에
아파트를 팔기 시작했는데 그 아파트를
중국인들이 다 받아갔다는 거예요.
그래서 그 이면의 뜻은 뭐냐면 어
지금 이재명 정부가 그런 정책을
했는데 수혜는 강 중국인들이 봤다.
뭐 이런 내용이에 들어가 있는 거죠.
그러면서 또 하나 의미는 뭐냐면 강남
아파트는 여전히 좋기 때문에 누군가
계속 사고 있다. 그리고 돈 많은
중국인들이 사고 있다. 이런
얘기입니다. 자,이 글에 대해서
이재명 대통령이 SNS에 글을
올렸는데요. 구체적인 수치를
얘기합니다. 가짜 뉴스다. 이건 가짜
영상이다라는 거고요. 직접 확인해
봤더니 1월부터 4월에 강남구의 집합
건물 즉 아파트를 포함한 집합
건물에서 중국인 매수가 다섯 명이
불가능 불가했다. 그런데 어떻게
짝스를 해 갔냐 이런 거죠. 명백한
허위 뉴스고 또 하나 뭐냐면 증을
부축이는 어 명백하게 나쁜 뉴스다라는
이야기를 합니다.
전이 뉴스가 굉장히 심각하다고 봐요.
단순하게 한 뉴스에 그치지 않고 이런
이야기들이 계속 누적돼 왔거든요.
그래서 여러분들한테 일단 보여
드리겠습니다. 뭐가 진실인지 이재명
대통령도 얘기했지만 뭐가 진실인지를
제가 조사를 해 봤는데요. 통계치를
한번 보시죠.
이건 강남삼국, 강남구, 서초구,
송파구, 송파구의 최근 외국인들이 몇
명을 샀는지 나타내는 수치입니다.
예를 들어서 2026년 4월에
외국인들이 강남 3구에서 67명이
아파트를, 집합 건물을 매수합니다.
근데 그중에서요. 중국인은 다섯 명에
불과했습니다.
>> 근데 반면에 외국인 중에서 미국과
캐나다인이 대부분을 차지합니다.
>> 여러분, 저런 뉴스를 내려면요.
미국인이었어야 돼요. 캐나다에서
샀다고 했어야 돼요. 그런데
중국인이라고 그냥 해 본 거예요.
근거도 없이
>> 그게 계속 뭔가 생각을 그런 쪽에
맞추다 보니까 누군가 얘기하고 그게
확증 편양으로 방송까지 이어지고 주력
언론이라고 하는 서울 경제 TV에서
그런 얘기를 한 겁니다. 굉장히
심각한 거죠. 그런데 이게
계속됐다는게 어떤
거냐면 그 내용을 볼까요? 그렇다면
저 미국과 캐나다인는 누구일까요?
보면 다음 장을 볼까요? 대부분
미국에 살고 있는 한인들이 삽니다.
>> 미국에 있는 쉽게 말해서 교포들이
강남 아파트를 엄청나게 사는 거예요.
엄청나게 나는 표현을 뺄게요.
대다수의 외국인들은 미국이나 캐나다에
살고 있는 한인들이 강남 3구의
아파트를 샀습니다.
그런데 중국인이라고 한 거예요. 근데
그러니까 조사도 안 하고 그리고
중국이라고 생각하고 기사를 그냥
쏟아낸 거죠. 명백하게 이건 협중
이야기고
사실을 적시한다면 이렇게 얘기됐어야
됩니다. 미국인들이 사고 있다.
캐나다인들이 사고 있다. 그래서
미국인들이 강남 아파트를 쓸러가고
있다. 이렇게 얘기했어야죠. 그런데
중국인이라고 얘기한 겁니다. 이게
단순하게 뭐 일회성의 문제가 아니고
이게 계속돼서 이야기가 되었단
말이죠. 다음 차 한번 보실까요?
이런 뉴스들 검증되지 않는 뉴스들이
나오다 보니까 국힘의 기운 위원은
최근에 중국인들이 부동산을 사게 하면
안 된다라는 법도 발휘합니다. 그런
가짜 뉴스의 편승에서 법을 만들고
법을 만들려고 하기도 했어요. 지금
대한민국의 모습입니다. 출발점이
있죠. 그런 언론들이 그런 근거도
없는 뉴스들을 내고 그리고 증과
부추이고 그걸 또 국힘해서 받고 그게
실제적으로 정책에 반영되고 이런
것들이 반복되고 있었던 거죠. 다음
장을 한번 보시면 언론들이 어떻게
계속 얘기하냐면 이런 겁니다. 전액
대출로 강남 아파트 쇼핑하고 있다.
중국인 집주인 넘쳐난다. 그러면서 또
우리 국민들도 어 불안이 좀
쌓이거든요. 보세요. 중국인 강남
아파트 쇼핑 가만두냐 난리나자 뭐
조사한다.
>> 네. 이런 보수적인 경제지들이 계속
이런 것들을 얘기합니다. 근데 사실
관계도 틀리다는 얘기예요. 어
우리가이 문제에 대해서 계속 얘기를
하는 이유입니다. 한국의 보수
경제들이 얼마나 큰 피해를 미치고
있고 잘못된 기사들을 쏟아내고 있고
어이이 문제를 우리가 계속 이야기하고
지적하고 고쳐 나가야 된다. 특히
경제를 얘기할 때 그동안 우리는 이제
정치를 많이 얘기했잖아요. 정치는 어
그런 언론들이 잘못된 점을 많은
국민들이 알고 있어요. 그래서 뭔가
좀 이렇게 기사를 볼 때도 가려보고
이러는데 특히이 경제들의 저런 터문이
없는 이야기들은 은연 중에 좀
받아들이게 돼요. 그런 생각을 좀 안
갖고 있더라고요. 그래서 저희가 이런
얘기들을 계속 해 나가고 있는
겁니다. 어 그래서 어 오늘은 제가요
말씀을 좀 드려보고 싶었고요.
한국의 경제들의 이런 보수와 또는
문제점들을 계속 지적해 보고 싶은
겁니다. 굉장히 심각하다. 어 그런데
말씀드린 것처럼 은연 중에 우리는
그거를 객관적인 기사로 받아들이고
그게 심지어 법으로도 재정이 되는
이런 상황이기 때문에 경제는요.
명확하게 데이터로 분석하고 그걸
기반으로 분 그걸 기반으로 해서
정책이라든지 방향성이 설정돼야 된다고
전 생각하고 있거든요. 정책하고 다른
거라는 거죠. 그래서 저희가 고민할
지점이 굉장히 많다.이 뉴스가
단순하게 뉴스에 그쳐서는 안 되고 어
한국의 경제를 이야기하고 특히
언론들의 문제까지도 확장되고 이걸
개선하는 노력들이 좀 지속돼야 되지
않겠느냐라는 생각을 하면서 여러분하고
공유드리고 싶었습니다.
>> 네. 네, 너무 좋은 말씀이셨고요.
그래서 이제 가짜 얘기를
계속 하고 있는 그런 언론이나 그
기사는 그냥 제가 볼 때는 진짜
쓰레기예요. 예. 그런 거에 너무
현혹되지 않으셨으면 하고요. 진짜
각성해야 됩니다.
>> 네.
>> 그리고 어 가짜 얘기 말고 진짜
얘기를 하는 행사가 있죠.
>> 그렇죠, 여러분. 네 진짜 얘기를
하거든요.네
>> 맞습니다. 어 주식가 가방에
오프라인 강연을 저하고 어 박정
대표가 같이 하는데요. 5월 30일과
31일에
>> 일산 파주와 위래 송파에서 어
가집니다.
>> 그렇죠? 네. 네이버에서 뭐 주식
과거방 이렇게 검색하셔도 되고 그냥
주화가.co.kr로
해 주셔도 됩니다.
>> 여러분 편하게 오셔서요. 그냥 잔소리
들으시면 돼요.
>> 맞아요.맞. 그냥 잔소리로 끝나나요?
버록
>> 광수한테 엄청 혼나고 가시더라고요.
눈물 흘리면서 갔더라고요. 예.
알겠습니다. 그 오프라인 강의에
대해서 말씀드렸고요.
>> 네.
>> 시간이 좀 있는데 시동 생각을 나눠서
>> 59분이에요. 59분이에요.
>> 시간 없거든요.
>> 아, 제가 이야기를 너무 많이 해서
죄송합니다. 다음 주에는 우리의 시동
생각을 집중적으로 듣는 시간을 갖도록
하겠습니다.
>> 네.
아, 오늘 금요일인데요. 여러분
1시가 돼 가고 있습니다. 저희가
마무리할 시간인데 오늘도 여러분들
사연을 좀 전해 드리면서 마무리를 해
볼까 합니다.
편지를 저희한테 예, 이렇게 보내
주신 분들하고 댓글을 남겨 주신
분들이 있는데요.
제가 첫 번째에 사연을 읽어
드리겠습니다. Mon, 님이 남겨
주신 글이요. 안녕하세요. 주식
아가방 함께 주식 투자를 시작한
주린입니다. 저는 2024년 갑상선
암을 선고받고 시간 대수를 하고
목소리가 제대로 나오지 않아 아직도
일상으로 돌아가지 못하고 있는
환자입니다. 몸은 회복되지 않았지만
어떻게 살아야 하나 막할 때 주식
아가방을 듣게 되셨대요. 그리고
ETF를 투자를 시작했다고 하십니다.
작년 10월 고민하다 남아 있던
보험금으로 코스피 200 ETF에
투자를 시작했고 며칠 전 받은
배당금을 어버이 날 선물로 엄마께
드렸습니다. 기쁜 마음을 공유하고자
글을 남깁니다. 오래오래 주식 시장에
남을 수 있도록 노력하겠습니다.
감사합니다.
어 저희 주변에 이런 분들이
많으시죠? 어 벽 이렇게 아프셔서 어
일을 못 하시고 되게 계신 분들이
많고 또 여러 가지 사정으로 해서
집안에서 일이 없이 계신 분들이
많습니다. 그러면 굉장히
무력해지시잖아요. 근데 이런 분들이이
투자를 통해서 아 내가 할 일을 찾고
뭔가 의욕을 찾는게 저는 의미 있는
일이라고 생각합니다. 그래서 저희가
어 이런 사연들을 때마다 굉장히
감사한 마음이에요. 어 우리 M님도
저희가 MLCC 얘기되었잖아요. 이제
MLC 공부를 시작하시면서
더 활력을 찾기 바라십니다. 근데
이렇게 할 일이 생기잖아요. 그럼
몸이 더 건강이지.
>> 예. 그래서 우리 M 님 파이팅.
예. 저희가 드리고요. 응원드립니다.
다음 메테오 님 사연이 왔는데요.
이건 또 우리 권당커 님이 한번 읽어
주세요.
>> 네.
네. 메테호님께서
댓글로 사연 남겨 주셨습니다.
군대에서 적금 말고 월급을 따로 모아
작년부터 주식 아가방을 보고 시동
선생님, 광수 선생님 말 믿고 PX
갈돈을 아껴 매달 정립식으로 모았는데
그 돈이 꽤 크게 굴려져서 목돈을 더
모으고 사회에 나갈 수 있게 될 것
같습니다. 곧 저녁인데 정말
감사합니다라고 보내 주셨네요. 아유,
이것도 너무 감사한 말씀인데 요즘에
>> 박수 대표님 일반 병사들이 월급이
얼만줄 아세요? 평균
>> 월급
>> 평균은 모르겠데 병장은 100만 원
넘지 않나요?
>> 맞습니다. 평균적으로 150만 원
정도 된다고 해요. 그래서 많은
분들이 또 투자에 관심을 갖고 있다고
합니다. 저희가
>> 군부대도 좀가 볼까요?
>> 군부대요?
>> 아,
>> 맞아요. 우리 장병 여러분 제테크
강연 같은 거 국방부 필요하면 연락
주십시오. 맞습니다. 근데 그 2년
가까운 기간 동안 월급 받으셔서
투자를 잘하시면 복돈이 마련되잖아요.
그럼 사회에 나오셔도 굉장히 도움이
많이 될 거 같아서 저희가 군인분들을
위한 그런 강연이나 방송도 좀 해
볼까 합니다. 의미가 있고 그런
노력들이 또 합해서 세상을 바꾸는
힘이 되겠죠. 네. 오늘 댓글
올라오시는데 제가 가슴 아픈 댓글
하나 봤어요. 음. 제가 스타벅스
가지 말자 해서 빈 사진 보여
드렸는데
자녀분이 스타벅스에서 일하신다고.
음.
>> 그런데 손님이 없는 거 어 너무
그렇게 얘기하면 나 가슴 좀
아프다라고 했는데 여러분 어떻게 해야
됩니까? 이거 어 우리가 스타벅스는
가지 않아야 되는데 거기서 일하시는
분들이 또 계시잖아요.이 문제를
어떻게 해결해야 되는지 제가 쉬는
기간 동안 그리고 어 그리고 부처님
오신 날 고민을 많이 해 보도록
하겠습니다. 그래도 일단 스타벅스는
가지 않고 예 우리가 뭔가를 변화를
일으켜야죠. 그리고 거기서 일하시는
분들을 위해서 우리는 뭘 할 수
있는지를 또 고민해 보겠습니다.
우리가 다 같이 함께하는 세상이니까.
12시에 만나 위해서는 이렇게 고민한
일이 많습니다. 여러분 우리 열심
저희 열심히 도와주시고요. 저희도
열심히 해 보도록 하겠습니다. 주말
잘 보내시고 어 부처님 오신 날
대체일이잖아요.
>> 네.
>> 아 저희 합니까, 안 합니까? 방송은
무조건 나갑니다.
여러분들 어 월요일에도 저희
찾아뵙도록 하겠습니다. 함께 해
주셔서 감사하고요. 행복하신 하루
보내시기 바랍니다. 고맙습니다.
감사합니다.
เฮ